they've run out of room at the morgue
but they haven't run out of respect for
the dead a Cremona hospital the next
batch of the lost waiting for cremation
are laid out in the hospital chapel
before collection their families
couldn't even say goodbye
they're all in quarantine it's a
recurring theme now everyone dies alone
[Music]
they came from here the hospital's
intensive care unit which is on the
brink of collapse
this is what it looks like when the
virus overwhelms and here in Lombardy
it's overwhelming these patients are
critically ill in all probability they
won't make it the staff have no cure
available to them they're just trying to
keep them along every 13 to 16 hours
they turn the patients over to relieve
the pressure on the lungs without doubt
she wouldn't survive without constant
attention
the patients are highly contagious where
possible they're observed from a
distance but most of the time that isn't
possible
[Music]
nobody takes any risks they wash and
sanitize constantly gloves masks and
protective clothes a regularly changed
in truth these men and women are
exhausted the system is at breaking
point and they are as well but they keep
going they aren't the frontline in this
war they are the only one so a very
dangerous disaster is a tsunami we are
here 12 hours a day only we are going to
fall for a few hours and come back here
for the work because we are here for the
patients the first perhaps only bit of
good news for the teams here is this man
we couldn't approach him he's still too
weak but he waved he is recovering after
two weeks he is getting better in that
two weeks though not one other person on
this ward improved or worse they died
what was really interesting here is that
now they've had to extend the intensive
care unit but now it is absolutely full
it's absolutely full in every hospital
in Lombardy they hoping that some can be
taken away and the other really
frightening development is that the
patients are getting and much much
younger because they are not being
treated in hospital because there's no
room for them now it's a big big change
because the virus has mainly affected
the older age groups now they're talking
about people in their 30s and 40s that
hasn't been seen anywhere so far the
only illness is being treated in Cremona
hospital now a link to the corona virus
and it's spreading
open this side of the parchment to
intensive care
only yesterday and today is really full
for so even in one day Emanuela
catenaccio is a neurosurgeon normally
now she's working in intensive care
she asked to send a message to the world
lockdown if you can see what's happened
another country or another part of your
country and wait to do something I think
now it's not more an option maybe at the
beginning we didn't know exactly what
would be happen but now we know what
happened it's you don't don't don't
think that it is happening here and it
counts happen everywhere else it will
because it will if you don't do anything
to stop it
in Lombardy they haven't run out of hope
but they're struggling with pretty much
everything else they're waiting for the
epidemic to peak but it could be weeks
it could be much longer
Sturm Zee Sky News Cremona Italy
you
[Music]